jeff bezos blue origin is launching its
second human flight on wednesday the new
shepard rocket will lift off from the
company's space port in west texas
carrying four space tourists on a 10
minute ride they are you know this name
star trek actor william shatner blue
origin vice president of mission and
flight operations that would be audrey
powers former nasa engineer chris
bashausen and healthcare entrepreneur
glenn devries we spoke to them earlier
this morning
hello and welcome please start us off
captain kirk we were all talking about
you this weekend and they said this is a
piece of cake for him because he's done
it before and i said listen that was a
tv show he never left the ground
so how are you feeling how wise of you
to talk about a piece of cake uh
and and the remnants of that piece of
cake this is no piece of cake but
we've delayed uh uh 24 hours because of
the winds and are
the enormous concern for our safety and
we welcome that that uh concern
glenn you're a licensed private pilot
you have some you have some feel for
what it's like to be up in the sky
what are you most looking forward to
i am actually looking forward to seeing
the earth from a different perspective
than i ever had before
i think it's going to be something that
we we've all heard people have done it
before us come down changed and i just
can't wait to stare at that window
and
feel differently about humanity in our
planet than i've ever had the
opportunity before
i know glenn that's what i think too you
can't possibly go up there and not come
back
unchanged i i so understand that audrey
powers you you know blue origin very
well former employees have raised some
safety concerns safety issues what do
you make of the concerns that they've
raised
well that just hasn't been my experience
at blue we're we're exceedingly thorough
i've worked on new shepard for eight
years now in a variety of roles and
i can't say enough about the team of
professionals that work on this program
from the from the earliest days um up
through now as we've started our human
flights and safety has always been our
our top priority and that that has
always been my experience here chris
you're a nasa engineer what does this
moment mean to you
yeah i'm very excited i've waited you
know my entire life to do this and i
think it's pretty amazing that 2021 is
the year that really the human race is
finally starting to go to space at scale
um and you know i think we'll look back
at this day 50 years from now and go wow
this really was a special time in
history just like the wright brothers
when people started flying passenger
planes so you know i think it's really
exciting to be part of history and can't
wait to fly
what i also think is important to
remember that jeff bezos's concept of
doing all this is to
uh build uh industry homes to live uh
in close connection with earth and uh
and function close to earth and that's a
vision that i think is very practical
and and worth getting behind i think
that's a good reminder for us all
william shatner but can i just say this
i want to be you when i grow up you're
90 years old they say that you will be
the oldest person going into space
you're in you you look great you're in
great shape clearly you've been enjoying
life why did you want to do it
because i wanted to claim that i was the
oldest person that went it's
what uh what a thing to have he's the
oldest guy that went into space i want
to have the vision i want to see space i
want to see the earth i want to see what
we need to do to save earth i want to
have a perspective that hasn't been
shown to me before
that's what i'm interested in seeing
i look forward to your return all of you
good luck good luck good luck
thank you
and so do we look forward to our return